all right here we are with another
version 14 design review
this one is about control and control
theory and system modeling
all right every time we do one of these
I learn a tiny bit more about this this
topic area which is not one that I've
ever really practiced
okay
so
the first functionality
is something that we plan to do more of
so if you have a model
how
you know tolerant is that of uncertainty
in some of the
things that go in let's say it's an
engineering model and you actually it's
a device you're going to build then
you're unlikely to be able to produce
identical parts or tolerances involved
and whatnot yeah yeah
okay so how much that the whole system
degrade
or vary in its performance does it even
stop working
I mean would you even ride in an
aircraft that hasn't been seriously
validated for that
yeah and you could say the same if you
if what the model you do is just kind of
like a prediction model more science
thing or a business thing
yeah show me an example of one of these
plots when the thing is
go to go to system uncertainty plots
okay
which one do I press here is it the DOT
we have an error here somebody knocked
out please
self-test error and axis box
yeah
okay got it
yep
so what it describes is the kinds of
systems it can take how do you specify
uncertainty you can use a round you can
use distributions
intervals
regions
uh
and you can even have sort of varying
input you know like
like a random process
this font should be smaller
certainly no bigger than the axis once
that makes sense
okay yeah
it's a little bit confusing that that
outer interval which is the the bounding
yeah
I don't even know whether going up to
100 makes sense do you have that
parametrizable
uh yes you can choose solar quantiles um
so yeah
this is kind of nice functionality it's
an interesting idea I mean
I'm kind of wondering you know in like
ND solve
why don't we have a similar thing
yeah so
uh parametric and we can build something
a new function that does it so
parametric and Diesel would be like a
building block to achieve that with yeah
that's kind of why we built built it but
I think that there's a bunch of these
end user functions
that one can build with that
and
what this does it's not that you
couldn't program it yourself and so it
does basically Monte Carlo simulation
uh parallelizes that yeah that's the
processing on top of it Etc
um it's not that you couldn't build it
it's just tedious as hell and yeah but
but
I'm kind of wondering for this
functionality why isn't there a general
Monte Carlo you know given a function
right as a function of
you know whatever it is why isn't this
just a general thing why is it specific
to system modeling
the ability to make
you know that type of plot like like
this type of plot how would I make that
type of plot is that that's not a
distribution plot is it no no no what is
it so we should have something that
makes this type of plot from data
right it's kind of like a version of a
histogram plot
yeah I think that that we should
probably do that for plot and other
things that makes it easy if you specify
uh
that you know the the the the the sort
of the rounds you know that depends on
on your variable and things like that
they're both plot and list plot
need to be able to make plots like this
am I making sense yeah you mean this
line plot right so listbot already does
intervals and stuff
no I understand that what I'm saying I'm
saying this type of plot where you're
showing the smooth you know or not so
smooth you know this this uh
uh sort of graduated color level thing
yeah
I don't see why we wouldn't do that for
you know given a list plot
well maybe list line plot but I don't
even know whether it's that functional
whether it's a you know
um
you know more like a
sort of you know distribution or
uncertainty or something uh variant of
let's let's plot just like we have this
step plot
you know this seems like another variant
of that family where where what's
happening is it's kind of list histogram
plot
right where at every every point I mean
we we had it a sign but it's it's
that the thing that's been put in now
for a point uncertainty for points if
you want uncertainty for point for
Curves and surfaces that's
what this could be for instance
or maybe it is another variant
yeah
I mean I think this is a generally
useful kind of plot where you've got
data
and
you need a full distribution at every
point exactly exactly but I mean this is
you know you know a histogram is just
one slice and this is a you know
histogram as a function of a parameter
yeah and these are slice distributions
as we call them for random processes
well I thought we had a function like
this for distribution I mean what what
is our distribution plot function
well we have for finite you know this
distribution chart and there is box
whisker chart or things to compare many
why is this okay oh node you've got to
trace why that documentation took
forever to Launch
Ed with us yeah
right so this is another version of how
to do this but only with discrete points
whereas here we're we're having a you
know a distribution as a function of
parameter yeah
and it seems like it really seems like a
generally useful thing that we should
support
and we should also support it in a
function that you plot if that function
has sort of uncertainty parameters I
don't know what happens if you say what
happens if I say plot around sine X
you know uh
0.2 cos x
I don't think it does anything at this
point
nothing
yeah
we have prototypes for these these
things
but it's we have to come back to
uncertainty
why did they put that brace in
lovely
um
interesting choice that it cut the
things off here oh no no maybe they're
zero yeah sorry they're zero though
yeah it's lovely okay
so in a sense this
is a Continuum limit of this
right
yes I mean this one shows
we show a Quant uh quantiles there this
one shows standard deviation
like around shows it's based on standard
deviation
yeah yeah right I understand
I really think this is a useful kind of
plot for both plot and list plot
now in terms of your very specific use
here
I mean God knows you know I don't know
I'm not in this business it looks it
looks nice
think that this packages up
uh you know a lot of results
in in sort of the the in in a in a
killer app which is to be able to look
at it and see is that is that where you
need to be or do you need to defer to
analysis
yes but now if I want the results in a
computable form how do I get them so in
the future we we will do more functions
um
this generates massive amounts of data
and
and so I think it's it's kind of good to
have things that can reduce the data so
one of the things that you want to do is
to certain kinds of
conditions that you'll want the system
to always satisfy for instance yes can
we validate that can we verify but the
probability that it will always do this
exactly exactly so what's the range of
of X values for which that will always
be guaranteed right exactly
so that's for the future that's that's
some confidence intervals some quantile
yes
so the various ways of quantifying that
and so we'll we'll do that you know but
but what it does is automate a lot of
data analysis on this massive amounts of
data yeah okay that's great
so how long do these things take to run
I mean if I just do this depends on the
system so it's going to do a lot of
simulations
you know of the same that's probably a
very simple system so it's probably not
too bad
but lovely if there was a little bit
more indication of what's actually
happening okay loading documentation
examples is sort of unclear why I would
need to load documentation examples for
this but
whatever
I mean at least it's honest about what
it's doing
plotting progress what do you mean it's
plotting progress It's not plotting
progress what the hell are you doing
there what are you talking about
uh it's a bad way to say it okay who's
who's making sure how does this work how
do we get these things edited
uh I can I can fix the title no no no no
no no no no who I want to know the
process by which we figure out
okay I don't I have no idea why this
plot is so tiny but but I guess I can
make it bigger
um
I assume you can switch off this Legend
right yes
so okay let's talk about progress
monitoring in general what who do we
have from project management here
uh Eli
okay
so I'd like to know you know all kinds
of Kernel developers are adding progress
monitoring which is good
Roger maybe you have a comment on this
how are we centrally dealing with the
wording for that progress monitoring I
don't think we are Stephen so I think
it's again
okay fine all right so that where should
that be done
what should the process be
I mean the very least it has to go to
dqa but I think but I now that I think
about it I don't think I've ever even
seen the the text for any progress
monitor but I you know and I should
actually review that too just as we do
documentation yep
so okay so look let's get a process the
dqa wouldn't dqa wouldn't have caught
what you caused no no it would not have
caught that but it will catch other
things which you know the last thing we
want is a spelling mistake which could
happen without absolutely dqs
so I mean well you're reviewing
documentation but whatever Process
reviews documentation
where where are these progress I mean
are these things you know burnt into the
code or are they in resources I think
they're all burned into code okay fine
well then then we need our node we need
some way to extract these
and tag whether they have been reviewed
or not
I mean for example they certainly will
be in pull requests right
a node
yeah I'm thinking I I think we need to I
need to check on this but uh
yeah with Roger or etai or somebody that
knows how this is implemented these
progress monitors because I don't know
if you can easily programmatically
extract all of them I don't think that's
how that works
okay well so or or even like you know
like I'm not even sure it does it can be
localized for example I don't think it's
that organized it's
I mean uh okay well then developer needs
to look and say like this is probably
hard right this is probably hard-coded
in the source code somewhere but yeah I
agree which is what needs to happen for
a lot of these progress monitoring
things but we just need a process where
people understand just like you know
we know we have to review what the plot
looks like in the end but the progress
monitor is also something that is seen
so to speak right but like the you know
messages are in a separate resource file
and then absolutely something that's
going to easily be done by dqa this is
this is sort of like you know it's not
quite a slice
okay simulation progress is not really
what what should it be saying running
simulation running no I mean what does
this mean running 51 of this is just
totally muddled
right running 50 151 of 200 simulation
instances it probably should say
it's okay top things should no no but
but you know I need to see the actual
list of these okay we need to see the
list of all of these things and then go
through so again I don't know what we
are consistently doing for this top
level piece
running simulation I suspect is what we
should be saying all right here
you know 151 or running simulations
plural
okay and then at the bottom you know 151
of 200 simulation instances or something
I don't know but it got to be you know
it's got to be consistent with the you
know and I don't even know about the
capitalization of that thing at the top
blah blah blah I mean we just need
standards and we need to know how we're
getting these reviewed
Fair
yep
and Roger Eli can I don't know how we
should centralize this because a bunch
of different groups I mean I think many
of the progress monitoring people are in
the Roger Empire
but not all no but I I mean now that
you've you've pointed that out I'll
certainly change how we do things you
know and we'll we'll extract them out so
we can actually look at them I said fine
cartoon fine fine but we just need we
need a standard for what they're
supposed to say we have you know it I
think was the one who defined a bunch of
them and he probably knows what some of
those standards are
so maybe he's a reasonable reviewer for
these things or pick one or two
reviewers who know the standards for
these progress monitors at least for the
next you know couple of versions those
people can review and then other people
can learn how those things should be set
up and then we like can take a note and
send it to like LCC then that's probably
a good place to review that that system
uh t-lcc yes I think so it's as as good
a place as any place and it's it'll uh
it's the right group of people that can
uh you know where that can be discussed
yeah it is an LCC issue actually so yeah
okay well looks nice like a nice
function but for gonna sake let's figure
out how to move it out into the general
plotting functions as well
yep um no that was the intention in this
it might be a driver for that so
okay
um
the next
unless you have more things to go over
no I don't know the next one is
um
is the so when you have a discrete
device like a computer
uh interfacing with A continuous device
like physics
um I don't think physics is this is
continuous but not at the scale you're
talking about it's continuous go ahead
exactly I knew you would say that but
so the the thing is that you want to
simulate them together you want to see
how they behave together yep so you need
to be able to simulate mixed mixed
continuous time discrete time
systems and this is what this adds and
specifically
what you have is that you know the way
you go from continuous time to discrete
time is to sample
and the way you go from discrete time to
continuous time is in some form of
extrapolation and they are usually
called hold zero order hold first order
hold those are unbelievably engineering
terms but that's exactly what people
recognize
wow okay
it's okay
so and so if you're a hardcore engineer
like musk or someone like that you know
exactly what we're talking about okay
the the if I took an interpolating
function and I applied sampler model to
it when I get the step thing
yes yes if interpolation order zero no
no I know that but I'm just saying
if I take an actual interpolation
yeah but it's it's by the way by the way
this this typing is dragging something
is very very wrong here
our node
typing is dragging and this version and
with what I'm doing am I making sense
yeah I'm not safe to notebook and I see
if it's a notebook issue or if it's a no
it I don't think it is I've been seeing
this issue for a while
well it's something it stuck your tools
it's uh you know one of those doesn't
get open it's a dynamic that's off
screen I mean there's like 20 different
things it could be so kind of
at the very least I'm gonna need that
notebook to uh to try to introduce and
Define reviews okay
okay so if I now say Eli make a note of
that sorry sorry oh God it's just crazy
this thing is just crazy I think it's
something to do with the autocompleta I
mean there was this there was this clue
that the first two letters might be slow
but it's slow all the way through
yeah
it's the Prototype built Steven so that
might be so we can't release this okay
so that we're not releasing we're not
really it's not a function Stephen it's
a model
oh
yeah yeah
hook it up with that simulation function
input output model simulate is a sec
yeah the second example
oh boy
I hope people are using all this stuff
it's its own world
um
it's a big world
when did we introduce this
this is the input output model
simulation is new for this this part of
this design review
I see
though
but there need to be two model blocks
that are the bridges between discrete
and continuous time
and those that's that's what those two
are
what is the sample model open close
sorry what well why does it say
supplemental open closed though that's
the default
it it assumes that it assumes parameters
in that model but then there are you can
specify you can customize that model
based on
well it's assuming basically that that
model is just saying x equals x so to
speak it's just giving sample time
one that's a very slow sample time for
most systems
okay
so how would I do something
God I hate the way that this is R equals
I hate that but anyway whatever
um
how do I specify a much shorter sampling
time yeah you you'll give an association
okay yeah and then sampling period goes
to
whatever you want
okay
now that's different from what I would
get if I said plot sine X
x02 Pi interpolation order oh God this
is driving me crazy this this speed
thing interpolation order zero
no we don't have that for plot no no
but we did uh but we do actually
but wait a minute it's just for list
plot
yes for this plot for plot we don't for
for this line plot we do I see
why don't we for well it doesn't make
any sense for the plot
because it's really changing the
function
right okay so that's pretty funky what
it's doing here yeah yeah I
it doesn't look right
it looks like some kind of anti-alias
thing or aliasing phenomenon
um
I think that's that's uh
uh where what's the problem there super
is that yeah I have to follow that's
what's coming from Andy soul and when
event
it's what is yeah this is something I
wanted I wanted to yeah towards the end
I will I was going to bring it up with
that team
um do you think that's missing events
which is at least easy to answer the
reason that autocomplete's not sorted
um hey I'm not sure what's yeah but I
yeah I I there are two whether it's
missing events or it's that the plot is
missing it
the plot sampling is missing it yeah
it seems unlikely
anyway we can answer Sanders question on
the live stream the reason these things
are not sorted is because it wouldn't be
useful to sort them they want to put the
things that are most likely first
iron has a lot of very obscure things
that it could be it could be an inverse
Jacobi function sorry not what you want
I mean that's the whole art of
autocomplete just how you sort it
um
okay
so
this
is then returning
Yeah by default it Returns the output
response of that of that model
and I don't understand how does plot
work here I mean this thing what is this
thing if I want to find out the value of
this at that point
what do I do can I take yeah you can
substitute T you can replace t with that
of those I mean here
oh I see I see here I've got it to an
interpolating function yeah right right
so then all of the workflows that are
available for that or no
you plug into those words model simulate
basically turns this
into a univariate interpolating function
in this case yeah it can be back to
valued but yeah okay okay so this is the
this is the way of going from
a model so I mean I could could I take
some other kind of model like one of
your um
uh
yeah it accepts all those models yes
sorry
um
so you mean if I could take
one of these what are they called the
ones the ones that you feed into
arduinos what are those called yeah the
state space model transfer functional
yeah yeah it accepts all of them
okay so I could finally find out what a
state space
model
needs to be a numeric model not symbols
in it right so yeah if desolve can
handle it then it can be symbols but you
have but generally not
okay so now this I want to say here
why is it pink
I haven't had a clue now how do I give
variables here
no you just if you want to give an input
like sine t
just like before the input is does one
input so just sine T and then T goes
from 0 to 2 pi yeah
just percent
not super exciting
oh there's no Dynamics yeah there is no
Dynamics in you
that first Matrix there is zero so
there's no nothing happening in it okay
so what do I do I add it make it a
negative value so yeah negative value
otherwise it's unstable
okay
okay so that's
now is there an analytical might there
be an analytical version of this yeah
this one for sure
yeah you can just give T oh yeah instead
of T going you can the range you just
give it t
wow
so but that has nothing to do with
simulate
well solving and simulating is sort of
the same right yeah but it's not because
this is normal school result
right
and I would never guess that a function
which had the name simulate could give
an article result
this is kind of nice I mean this kind of
turns
this
I mean we haven't had this level of
Simplicity in getting output from
control system stuff before have we
there has been State response and output
response and you could get that result
in this case the the case that you give
there we could do before
but how does what does State response
take as input a state space model the
same thing so if you yeah
so we had the
okay
and then what you just get the same
arguments sign TT
okay yeah and yeah the re there is yeah
because the the stage response and
output response does not give all the
internal signals when we have like
interconnected models that's why we we
now have this new design with this
simulate and the data function
so when you put when you wire systems
together you don't want to flatten it
and get rid of it
so you often want to put like little
probes like an oscilloscope somewhere
you know like measure what does this
what's the signal on this wire and that
wire
so for instance
when you wire up a control system to a
plant
which means a physical model
then you kind of want to know what's the
control effort how much energy am I
pumping into the system
can I even do it okay so if I take a
thing like this
I don't even know how many sort of input
wise the thing has
yeah this also has one
how do you know that well a
dimensionality of the matrices yeah okay
I just don't know which dimension right
right I mean it's very similar to what's
happening with tensors in in machine
learning pipelines is it not I mean this
thing
is can you not put these in series and
so on yes
okay
so again that's a okay it's got one
input if it had multiple inputs I would
just give a vector there yes
yeah and you've got a list of two
because that model has two states
okay
so now what's the relationship between
input output model simulate and state
response
so input output model simulator sort of
next level up in sophistication
for two reasons two important reasons
one is what Suba mentioned that you can
you can say what it is that you want to
get out
which is incredibly hard which takes a
lot of coding because you have to kind
of do it yourself
with the previous ones
um what do you mean you want to say what
you want to get out where do you say it
look at the reference page output model
simulate
yeah that first illustration will show
so
so now we can place probes anywhere in
that model
okay so this is what can go in yes
not just a differential equation
difference differential difference and
combination of those yeah but but how
are those packaged I mean if I just give
y double dot you can't give it right in
here I hope but you know when you create
a state space model you can give a set
of differential equations
if you give y double dot you will wrap
it around State space model or one of
those models and get that and get uh one
of these based model around it yes
around the differential equation yeah
yeah okay
okay
okay so now this is what you can get out
output response Etc is that correct yeah
yes
so I mean in this case here for example
if I went here
and I said um
and this and I said something like
the last argument
which is not Auto completing please fix
yeah because the documentation is still
well one I think sometimes they have
names Stephen their models can store
names this one didn't have any
so there's just the default number
you know position names basically yeah
this
you know sometimes like particularly
Real World Systems you often have names
you say like this is the Hydraulics I
understand why did this not work yeah
yeah so I'm deciding what to do with
this this one has no subsystems that
subsystem only works for systems
connections models
okay so produce a message and yeah yeah
I
I'm going to generate a message yes okay
all right let's talk about the name
again
input output model simulate
so
is it true that
I mean input output models are like a
name in economics and so on and they
mean something quite different from this
I think there
is difference then the input output
model just means a model with inputs and
outputs I know but this is the standard
term of Art and control theory
yes
okay but how does it relate to the input
output models of economics
yeah it's similar you know they they the
inputs are usually called exogenous
inputs you know
for who for control theory no for you
know in economics
you know so there there are two kinds of
models that frequently used there than
Dynamic models one is where
uh where there's only basically noise
input
like ARMA M.A those kinds of things
then when you also have exogenous input
that you can actually measure they're
usually called rmax arcs yeah Max Etc so
X is for the exogenous input side okay
and
um
they often use State space models and so
then they need an output too because
it's usually not interested in the full
state
okay so we already have the function
System model simulate right
yes
but that really is doing simulation
but this might be doing simulation or it
might be doing exact solving
yes
what would happen if we called this
input output model solve
does that not make any sense I mean it
really is look it's a thing where you're
giving an input and you ask what is the
thing going to do yes
I think Soul feels strange in this
context strange because it isn't really
solving it's not there's no X solving
for it's just running the model with
that input right
so
and put up a model response
is it consistent with State response
yeah actually it could be yeah yeah
I think that's a neutral word that
doesn't say whether it's no it's not a
bad idea Steven it's it's very
consistent with the previous names yes
well what about just input output
response
I forget the model
I think that's even better
okay
all right so we've got another function
then we've got input output response
well we've got input output response
data is it data or is it a function
it's it's that yeah so you can so from
this you can ask just the property data
and then it will return that data object
and then we can do we can query
properties I'm asking is that quotes
data object actually a function really
no what is how how is it primarily used
it's just something with an association
inside that you can pick at pieces of
and things yeah yeah so three yeah so if
this is lazy is it lazy
meaning that it computes things only
when it needs some some of them it
compute yeah so it depends what comes
out of uh that simulation so all what is
there
it has and then if it's something new it
computes later
okay yeah but in the simulation itself
covers the vast majority it it has been
so for example if I took it outside the
range there's two Pi would it know what
to do or is it no no it will not it'll
yes
it only yeah
okay
so okay
but so you think input output response
data makes sense what are some other
star data things in the um in the
control systems world
it's yeah right now so we've been we've
been moving from the name system we have
systems model controller data
okay
and then we have uh yeah system phone
controller data we
we
unified all the controllers into that
okay
okay but that's the star data that works
more or less the same way as the simple
output response data will work is that
correct yeah yeah
okay
all right well seems reasonable let's
take a look at this sum
so I mean if it's called input output
response do these properties make sense
is it just output then
I don't know no it makes sense because
it's the yeah they're all responses what
we're getting out all those properties
the weirdest responses okay okay State
response output will they respond in a
response in a sense that just give it an
input how does the model respond over
time
yeah
are we doing webinars and things about
all this stuff because all this stuff is
really quite complicated I mean it kind
of I mean do we have a course yet about
control theory uh we have one that's
about to launch we've just developed one
over the summer
great and yes we will be doing more
actually so here's a game plan so this
is uh the Wolfram modeling series which
will be jointly
um done by the system modeler team the
numerix team control Suba and the
calculus and algebra to some extent
and the format will be kind of like a
cooking show or a Home Remodeling show
so we'll do like a modeling project
um you know there's going to be a goal
you're going to go through the
you know to to you know how do you think
about it you showcase some things it's
like when you cook you don't necessarily
wait 45 minutes I do think the name
might I mean that these things called
wolfen models that come out of the
physics project so we have to you know I
guess
well from modeling is sufficiently
different from that that people won't
get confused but that would be I mean I
I think you might add system modeling or
something like that
if that's what it is
I'm making sense yeah I mean is pde this
pde modeling there's uh
the the the the sort of ode modeling
that System model does
um and there's uses of those ode models
like in control systems
and there are sort of other kinds of
analysis like asymptotics from calculus
now
it's very different I mean they
well probably someone as it's modeling
it's okay
it makes sense yeah I I think that this
will be
um I think we'll run a lot of episodes
of this yeah this is like a really good
idea yeah
so we're about to kick that off actually
will be weekly episodes just idea good
good all right anything else we should
make sure to look at yeah I just want to
clarify so is that name you say input
output model response no no input output
response okay
we don't you think we don't need model
okay well I don't know why would we put
model in they're all about models aren't
they
the thing you're feeding is a model yeah
you asking for the input output response
of that model yeah okay got it yeah yeah
it's kind of important that these
meetings that we actually I mean
I think that's what we decided
okay what else should we look at here
that's it
okay nice stuff
great thank you all right see you in
another design review soon all right
thank you bye bye